hello and welcome to med simplified
chia seeds are the edible seeds of a
flowering plant known as salvia
hispanica which basically belongs to the
mint family
chia seeds are oval and gray with black
and white spots having a diameter around
2 millimeters
the seeds are hygroscopic absorbing up
to 12 times their weight in liquid when
soaked in water
chia seeds have been used by humans for
centuries and their use dates back to
aztecs and the mayans where it was a
part of their staple diet
the seeds have medicinal applications
also and they made up an important part
of the ancient medicine
chia seeds are packed with nutrients and
minerals that can have huge positive
impacts on your health so in this video
we're gonna talk about health benefits
of chia seeds
number one they're good for digestion
chia seeds are enriched with viper
every 100 gram will give you close to 40
grams of dietary fiber fiber is an
excellent agent for digestion and
prevents constipation and a host of
other gastrointestinal problems the
soluble fiber in the seeds absorbs water
causing them to expand in your stomach
and increase your feeling of fullness
when you eat them
by letting you feel fuller despite
eating less chia seeds can help you
maintain a healthy weight
fiber also feeds the friendly bacteria
in your intestine which is important
keeping your gut flora well fed is
absolutely crucial for your overall
health
fiber also helps in relieving from bowel
inflammation irritability and helps in
regulating cholesterol levels as well
number two better heart health
chia seeds contain quercetin an
antioxidant that can reduce your risk of
developing several health conditions
including heart diseases
apart from quercetin these seeds also
contain other antioxidants like
chlorogenic acid caffeic acid and
camphor all
these antioxidants assist your body to
fight free radicals oxidative stress and
cell damage are caused by free radicals
antioxidants fight the production of
these free radicals which can damage
cell molecule and contribute to aging
and diseases like heart disease
cognitive loss and cancer
according to a few studies chia seeds
can also lower blood pressure in people
with hypotension which is a major risk
factor for heart diseases
number three chia seeds are good for
bones chia seeds have several nutrients
that are vital for bone health including
calcium magnesium and phosphorus
a single ounce of the seeds offers 18 of
your daily calcium requirement which is
essential for bone muscle and nerve
health
when compared chia seeds offer more
calcium than dairy products when
measured gram per gram
number four they have high protein
content
chia seeds are a good source of protein
they contain roughly 14 protein by
weight which is very high when compared
to most plants
they also have a decent mix of important
amino acids which means your body should
be able to utilize the protein they
contain
chia seeds really are an excellent
source of protein especially for people
who eat little or no animal products
chia seeds can be a great evening snack
and provide the needed protein for your
body
number five they are good for diabetes
like we just discussed chia seeds are
high in fiber huge spikes in blood sugar
levels after meals may also have adverse
health effects when they are excessively
high on a regular basis
studies show that fiber may help to
reduce insulin resistance and improve
blood sugar levels reducing your risk of
metabolic syndrome and type 2 diabetes
research has also found that bread
containing chia seeds triggers a lower
blood sugar response than traditional
breads which helps to prevent high blood
sugar levels
number six chia seeds contain good fats
chia seeds contain omega-3 fatty acids
omega-3s are super important they have a
wide range of benefits from fighting
depression to improving sleep to
reducing the risk of heart diseases
over half of the fat present in chia
seeds are omega-3 fatty acids
making it an excellent source of these
essential fats in our body
we have made a separate video on the
importance of omega fatty acids on our
channel
so you can check that out and the link
to that video is in the description box
down below
here are some of the products we
recommend if you want to try chia seeds
links are in the description box below
and thank you so much for watching see
you in the next video